D-Class Personnel are the cogs that keep the
machinery of the SCP Foundation running smoothly.
Unfortunately, things are rarely very smooth
for the personnel themselves. There’s a
reason that common knowledge basically states
the D stands for “Disposable.” The lab
rats of the SCP Foundation, D-Class is a role
that no one in their right mind wants to play.
But what if you didn’t have a choice?
What if, somehow, whether through a shift
in time and space, or being accused of a crime
you didn’t commit, you found yourself transported
to a cell at an SCP Foundation site? Once
there, you quickly realize how dire your situation
is. But there’s hope! Maybe. You overhear
your fellow inmates whispering about other
prisoners who managed to escape. Could you
use your knowledge of the SCP Foundation to
find your way back to freedom?
We posed this scenario, and question, to the
amazing fans of SCP Explained, and you told
us about all of the ways you would try to
escape from the SCP Foundation before your
inevitable termination - or worse, transmutation.
So let’s get right to it and see who would
make it out, and who would wind up in SCP-682’s
stomach.
JustDrake said, “Well, considering I’ve
quite enjoyed the VR game SCP: Labrat, I’d
wait for a good containment breach, maybe
release a few extra SCPs that may be contained
with me, trust no voice i hear (Looking at
you, SCP-939) and just make for some type
of hole created, or maybe sewage drain? I've
never beaten the game truthfully but it’d
be an adventure”
Video games are the best way to prepare for
real life! Everyone knows that! That’s why
Resident Evil made me great at killing monsters,
Animal Crossing made me a world-class fisherman,
and The Sims prepared me for those days when
the door to my room is suddenly replaced with
a painting of a clown! Really though, that
sounds like a solid strategy. Use the chaos
of a containment breach as cover, play Robin
Hood to some friendly SCPs, don’t follow
any voices, and see if you can Shawshank Redemption
your way to freedom.
What have you got to lose? Well, maybe your
life, but you probably wouldn’t hold onto
that for long at the Foundation anyway.
unwind said, “E Z P Z Having a leg up is
an understatement in this situation, having
watched scp explained videos we have a great
understanding about the foundation and the
scps even more so than the site director themselves.
Just claim to be an O5 Council member from
a parallel universe and when interrogated
drop some classified information only they
would know, you'd be such a valuable resource
they might even let you join their council.
Not only have you escaped D-class duties you've
also gained high amounts of power.”
Easy peasy indeed, just make an incredibly
bold claim and expose yourself as a potential
security risk! There’s a slim chance this
might work, but there’s also a pretty substantial
chance that the real O5 council will intervene
and decide to go ahead and terminate you,
just in case. At the very least, you’d likely
be placed in permanent protective custody.
But hey, maybe they’ll put you in one of
the comfy cells with a minibar and everything.
GamingRevelation said, “If I was escaping
I would use an audio clip of 682 screaming/destroying
things and play it when people or SCPs are
nearby. The sounds of 682 will scare people
away or make a good enough distraction for
any guard stupid enough to fight 682. I would
also email the audio file to myself, that
way I can use the audio file on basically
any device”
This is an interesting one! You’d need a
lot of factors to line up just right for this
one to work, from keeping your phone (or another
device) on your person in spite of being in
Foundation custody, to finding a WiFi signal
to access your email, to making sure that
your audio file plays loudly enough to be
convincing. Not sure what they have planned
for the next update, but currently the iPhone
doesn’t emit sounds at a volume loud enough
to break through walls.
There is a chance that the sound would strike
enough fear into the hearts of experienced
guards to throw them off for a while anyway!
Just make sure SCP-682 doesn’t find out
what you’re up to – it probably doesn’t
appreciate copycats.
Endertitan Gamezzz said, “I have a pretty
simple but solid escape plan I think:
STEP 1: Find out what site I'm at, what kind
of SCPs are contained there, are they dangerous
or harmless, how often are there containment
breaches, how often do D-Class die? If the
site seems safe enough then I'll just spend
my days meeting harmless SCPs like 999.
STEP 2: If the site is dangerous, then I need
to do everything in my power to make sure
I'm not cross-tested with a dangerous SCP,
if that means stabbing my eye out or cutting
off my leg I'll do it, I'll do anything short
of killing myself if it keeps me away from
the likes of 106 and 682.
STEP 3: Try and see if any of the SCPs could
help me escape, for instance, if 738 is at
the site then I'll find a way to get crossed
tested with it, and then ask to be free from
the foundation and have all my criminal records
wiped, sure it'll cost me but hey, at least
I'll be free. Or I could find a Keter class
SCP and see if we could help each other break
out, it's a risky option but once again I'd
do everything in my power to stay away from
the lizard.
STEP 4: If all else fails then I'm either
gonna have to wait for or cause a massive
containment breach, then I can escape in the
confusion (all that time playing SCP Secret
Lab will come in handy) once again its a risky
option and I don't really like my odds but
I'll take my chances if I have too.
STEP 5: If I die (and let's be honest I most
likely will) then I only have two requests
for the foundation, one, that they actually
decide which SCP 001 is the real SCP 001,
and two, that my tombstone read "SUBSCRIBE
TO SCP EXPLAINED BECAUSE THEY MAKE FUN AND
ENTERTAINING VIDEOS! also screw the lizard."”
First of all, this isn’t a simple plan by
any means. It’s not a Canadian rock band
formed in 1999,
and it’s actually got quite a lot of detail.
You’ve thought long and hard about this!
And we appreciate that! One note though, making
a deal with SCP-738 might not just cost you.
A previous D-Class was offered freedom by
the entity, at the cost of his best friend’s
death. Even after he took that deal with the
devil, he was recaptured by the Foundation
a mere five hours later. You can decide for
yourself if that’s really worth it. But
hey, if you’re that desperate, then go right
ahead. At least you’ve prepared for the
very worst.
The first of your posthumous requests will
likely be denied, if we’re being honest.
And the second request is very sweet of you,
look I’m blushing! But also, we’d prefer
if you didn’t put a Foundation target on
our backs by pointing out how many of their
secrets we’re revealing. You’re right
about one thing though. Can’t stand that
lizard.
Juan Torres said, “We’re going to need,
a teddy bear, an aluminum coated box, a chair
and desk, an intact human nervous system,
a dart gun, and lawn mulch.”
Wait, don’t stop there! You’re just going
to give us a list of ingredients and not finish
the recipe? I already went out and bought
all the stuff, and the nervous system won’t
stay fresh forever!
Superhamster said, “Plug 079 into the wi-fi.
It could cause a breach big enough, so hide
during the breach and then escape the ruined
facility. Let me explain further - 682 and
079 bonded, and 682 is famous for containment
breaches. 682 is very hard to re-contain.
So, if you help 079, he'll help 682, which
will help you. Also, many other dangerous
SCPs will be breached.”
Now this is thinking big! Sure, you’ll be
exposing the entirety of the world wide web
to an aggressive, unpredictable, and downright
rude Artificial Intelligence, but you’ll
probably be able to escape back into the world.
Who knows how much of the world will actually
be left after you’ve unleashed 079, 682,
and a whole host of other dangerous anomalies,
but the remaining rubble will be your oyster!
Creature Savage said, “Assuming I'm at a
site with an intelligent SCP that's known
for escapes, such as 682, I'd offer it a chance
at freedom if it helped me escape, and we'd
both take off for the infinite IKEA. Of course,
I could also offer Fernand the Cannibal my
services as a jester for his protection all
the way to and through the infinite IKEA”
Fernand the Cannibal! Now you’re talking!
If you manage to team up with that gargantuan
gentleman, he could definitely be a big help.
Just make sure he stays well-fed, or your
new friend is going to start wondering how
you taste with fava beans and a nice chianti.
Otherwise, though, he’d love to have someone
listen to his stories and take the high part
during his favorite songs. Once you’re free
though, why not shoot for the stars? No need
to fend off the murderous staff of the Infinite
Ikea, just go to a regular Ikea and get a
new couch and some meatballs. No monsters
necessary.
DelayAnimation said, “Before escaping, there
are multiple problems to overcome. You have
to know the layout, Guards Patrol Paths, camera
placement, which Keycards you need, which
opportunities are best to escape. And once
you managed to find all of that out and escaped
to the outside you are still not done. Depending
on if you were in a Site or Area, the bare
wilderness surrounding a Site would be enough
to wreak havoc on you. Not to mention the
Watchtowers and outside Patrols. If you were
in an Area the Foundation would most likely
have Agents in the town surrounding the Area.
In conclusion, it is not possible to escape
the Foundations grasp. The only way to not
wind up as a Class D is to not do anything
to become a Class D.”
You know what they say, the best defense is
a good offense! An ounce of prevention is
worth a pound of cure! However, there’s
not much offense or prevention you can do
when a temporal anomaly thrusts you into a
parallel universe and plops you down right
in the middle of a D-Class cell. So, even
if you keep your hands clean your entire life
you might just find yourself in the custody
of the SCP Foundation anyway. It’s a nice
idea to think that just making all the right
choices will prevent you from being falsely
imprisoned by a secret organization, but sadly
life - and wormholes - just don’t work like
that.
Zagham Shebaz Karim said, “The best thing
to do, is to make allies. First of all, you
need to get as many D-Class Personnel on your
side as possible. Ask them what duties they
are on and use your information to help them.
Also, use them to find out what your duties
are going to be as they will have connections.
You need to stay on the down-low, as if you
are found out you will be experimented on
or worse. But, you don't only want to make
allies with the D-Class, armed with the knowledge
from SCP Explained you are able to guess/
approximate which facility you are at, what
SCP's might be there, and who the staff are.
With that knowledge, you can approach some
of the kinder staff and build your relationship,
so in case you get caught when escaping you
have a fall back or someone that can bail
you out of deadly punishments. You also want
to be resourceful and map out the place to
identify escape routes and the armory/ weapon
storage facility.
Next, you want to form better relationships
with some of the SCP's. Before terminations
roll around, you want to arrange a day that
the D-Class Personnel help some SCP's out
of containment. Mostly non-deadly ones as
you do not want to make an enemy out of the
SCP Foundation. But enough to distract the
guarding personnel. Also, with your close
contact with facility members, you have a
better chance at stealing credentials/ passes
to allow yourself through doors and escape.
But that isn't all, there actually might be
some SCP's on site that will make escaping
easier and your goal should not be just your
own escape, but escaping with as many D-Class
Personnel as possible. You want to equip them
with passes, all of them should know only
1 specific escape route which they themselves
or a few others are going, so that even if
they are caught, the others will not be found
out. And you want a few of them to escape
before everyone else and cause a ruckus outside,
making it look like the whole group has escaped,
sending guards behind them.
They will need access to a vehicle, so that
needs to be secured from one of the staff
which could be captured during the escape
and used for a way out or you could steal
their keys earlier, depending on the situation.
You yourself and a few others head to the
armory, to secure weapons, not only to escape
but to protect yourself from SCP's in the
future. Then you need to secure vehicles for
the group, which you will need to put distance
between the facility and your group and stay
away from other nearby facilities.
You need to stop at a certain point and go
to the nearest hospital to check for body
implants or anything that can be used to track
you, changing clothes and continuing on by
foot. At this point, your group can choose
to separate, live collectively, and stay alert
of the Foundation or join another organization”
This is probably the longest response we received,
and we just had to include it to applaud the
dedication and thought at play here, as well
as the selflessness! You’re not just planning
for your own rescue, no, that’s too small-time
for Zagham. You’re planning to liberate
every D-Class you can, and potentially start
your own brand-new society together. Make
sure you have a nice talk with them about
the rules for your new community, such as
“absolutely no stabbing your neighbors,”
and enjoy all the great, trauma-free barbecues
that follow.
Plot Armor said, “I would either attempt
to cause a containment break or steal an anomaly
like SCP-268. Still, first I would draw thaumaturgic
symbols all over my body and clothes like
Kalphastian isle which will make me resistant
to physical damage that will help me survive
containment breach.”
Bringing thaumatology into the equation is
a brilliant move. You’d likely be the only
D-Class on site with any knowledge of that
work, or the symbols. You’ll have to act
fast though, and work your magic before the
Foundation figures out what you’re up to.
If you don’t, they’ll likely wipe your
memory with amnestics or just terminate you
on the spot. The trickiest part of this plan
is probably finding something to write with,
you can’t exactly ask to borrow a pen. But
between those and the hat, you could probably
slip out unnoticed and unscathed!
Jacob Oddie said, “I'd just do my best to
find Mr. Peanut so I could die relatively
quickly/painlessly”
Why would that kill you? Are you allergic?
…Just kidding, we know you’re talking
about SCP-173. As bleak of an answer as this
is, we have to commend your honesty, and the
self-awareness it takes to look at the dangers
of trying to escape the SCP Foundation and
simply saying: No, I’d rather not.
Just another person On The Internet said,
“Well, taken with someone who has a very
short attention span and who is a procrastinator
with ADHD, I could request a test with Miss
J to see how it would affect someone like
me. Then I could escape and live the rest
of my life in peace and solidarity.”
Miss J did help a previous D-Class leave the
Foundation behind and start a new life, so
why not you too? We’re sure you’ll be
a model pupil, and wish you luck in whatever
discipline you decide to pursue! Don’t forget
your number 2 pencil.
Milo Knight said, “SCP-6113 is a pretty
surefire way to get out. Assuming you meet
the criteria you can suddenly have a different
name and appearance, and you won't really
be on any Foundation records. Use that to
plead your case. Just pray you don't get terminated.”
This would be a pretty drastic choice, and
you’d probably have to double down on the
whole “new life” thing since none of your
loved ones will recognize you - or you can
just tell them you got extreme reconstructive
surgery, I guess. But it’s better to be
alive in a new body than dead in your usual
one! As long as you’re able to avoid detection
following your transformation, and make sure
they don’t catch you on the security tapes,
this might just work.
Zadanoire 0203 said, “I mean... you can’t.
Yes you’ll survive until the monthly “termination”
but with how fortified these sites are, unless
you can get lucky with a containment breach
or are able to gain access to the sewer system,
you’re not escaping. and that’s not even
taking into account your spontaneous being
here and having great knowledge on the foundation
that you’d only really know if you were
a being above their perception. So on top
of that, there’s also the potential of you
being terminated for knowing too much, or
being contained as a new scp.”
Hey now, we didn’t say “reply with the
best way to bum us out!”
Really though, we see all of you hyper-realistic
commenters and we get it, really! But in a
world filled with killer statues and friendly
slime monsters, anything is possible. Sure,
most of the D-Class that wind up behind Foundation
walls wind up dead, but you could be the one
in a million who makes it out. Dare to dream!
Matt’s Magic said, “Easy, I simply say
"whoever shoots me or harms me is a rotten
egg" and then walk out unharmed. Due to the
fact the guards are in fact people, not eggs”
That’s it. You’ve cracked the code. Unless
the SCP Foundation starts hiring eggs as guards
or creates some sort of unholy human-egg hybrid
to staff their halls - we’re looking at
you, Humans, Refuted - their days of keeping
D-Class prisoners are over.
Thank you for participating in yet another
weird, wild community response video from
SCP Explained. What’s your favorite escape
attempt? Anything we missed? Let us know down
in the comments. And if you want a chance
to be featured in the next one, keep an eye
on our community tab for the next question.
And in the meantime, get back in your cells!
Now go check out “Your Questions for God
Answered” and “How To Actually Beat SCP-3008
The Infinite Ikea” for more questions and
answers from the SCP Explained community!